you know there is there's a very thin
dividing line between success and
failure when you start a business from
scratch you know if you don't have
enough money to pay the bills you go the
wrong side of that dividing line and if
you can somehow get enough money to pay
the bills
you stay the right side of that dividing
line you know I've always been running
running running faster than perhaps I
should me and I've have great difficulty
saying no to things so keep on taking on
new things and we've just managed to
stay the right side of the dividing line
over the last 50 years in business but
equally in those early days when you
when you're starting a business without
any financial backing it's it's it's
easy to slip the wrong side and and in
fact you know most entrepreneurs do do
slip the wrong side and the poor the
important thing is then just to you know
pick yourself up and you know start
again and if it doesn't work at that
time keep keep going until you do
succeed and not to give up if something
isn't working
I think you should stop doing it I think
you should quit and this runs contrary
to a lot of things that you've been told
in your business education through case
studies etc you've probably been told
that winners never quit and what I saw
through my research looking at lots of
successful people who've done a lot of
amazing things
winners actually aren't afraid to quit
winners quit all the time and so I think
it's not persistence that's the
predictor of success it's flexibility
and adaptation being willing to kind of
go down a path and say actually that's
not the right path for me I'm gonna go
back I'm gonna take the other path I'm
going to create an all new path so
winners never quit
maybe but winners actually give up all
the time thank you guys so much for
watching
I made this series because I wanted to
promote understanding and awareness I
wanted you to see that it's not always
looking at it as one thing or the other
but if you embrace the genius of the end
and bring those two seemingly opposite
points of view together that that is
where the true genius lies I want you to
see that you can learn from both of the
people that are profiled in the video
especially probably from the person who
you don't immediately agree
if you can understand their perspective
and apply it to your life chances are
it'll help you get to where you want to
go a lot faster so let me know what you
think leave a comment below I'll join
the discussion continue to believe and
I'll see you soon